[Music]
good to see you my friend it's good to
be back rich thanks for having me on
again always a delight to have you on
this is your third appearance on the
podcast but it's been like almost three
years since the last time you came on
yeah
the first time we went into your whole
back story in detail so for people that
are newer to the show definitely check
that out the second one was mostly about
your Sparta book and that whole
experience and now we're in a new
chapter but we have a lot to catch up on
you've done a lot since I've seen you
last
we both have yeah we're still standing
yeah we are somehow I don't know but you
have an age today so whatever you're
doing is working I'm telling you I'm
Chad kill me but I'm I'm keeping out I
don't know if it's killing you I think
it's making you younger what is the
secret like longevity is one thing I
definitely want to explore with you so
you're what six now 55 I'm getting up
there you're getting out okay come on
well chronologic chronologically o'clock
I'm above 55 chronologically
biologically I'm in my 30s you look
great
you're as fit as ever you're still
getting after it like crazy doing all
kinds of crazy adventures and stuff and
well you know that Blue Zones yes I take
it so one of them is an island in Greece
called Acadia were Icarus you know the
waxed wind landed and that's the island
my mom is from so Acadia is the highest
concentration of centenarians on earth
so maybe that has to do with it
maybe the genetic lineage plays into
this a little bit you're always
crediting your genetics but lifestyle is
a big aspect of that I mean one thing
all the blue zones share in common are
these various principles that have
nothing to do with genetics and
everything about how everybody lives day
to day mm-hmm and you seem to be able to
create your own little blue zone up in
Marin I mean you still you don't own a
car do you yeah you pretty much run
everywhere you keep your life very
manageable I remember when we first met
and you've been like a mentor to me over
the years and no that was a paid
endorsement people
yeah then like a huge in addition to
being you know a great inspiration to me
you've been very helpful to me and have
always been somebody I can count on with
great advice and and I believe if
recollection serves me that I asked you
know I was asking you like how did you
this is the very beginning of me
starting out and trying to figure out
how to make a vocation out of doing the
things that I love and you were sharing
about your you know basically your
experience and and you said you know I
don't like one thing you learned in the
corporate world is that you didn't
really want to manage people and so and
so and I remember that very vividly
because now I'm in a situation where I
am managing people and I would say it's
not my strength I'm trying to place over
there laughing employees laughing now
yeah you know I'm trying to grow into
that and learn that but but that's
something that you were very clear about
who you are and you've kind of you've
organized your life to to be able to do
what you love doing but also keep it at
a certain scale so it doesn't interfere
with the things that you love the most
yeah and I mean that that involves
making choices right yes I'm sure you
say no you have to say no we have to say
no a lot and you have to actually be
content once in a while which I'm not
very good at being content but you have
to say look I've got enough like I could
make this bigger mm-hmm it could be
something more but it's gonna take a lot
out of me and I don't want to go there
so these are like personal decisions you
got to look inward I think to make I
just know I'm that good like you know
when people are involved things get
weird as to other people is there
anything you said no to where afterwards
you were like maybe I should have done
that there's been a couple car deals oh
really yeah where oh my god that'd be so
nice but people know I don't drive and I
haven't owned a car and over like a
Volkswagen gave you a car once you got a
car I think when I went to your house
you got a car you were like I never
drive it but they gave it to me and
that's why I felt so disingenuous in
that relationship and that sponsorship
relationship that I said I can't keep
going on with this I mean I'm driving at
a thousand miles a year right so it's
just it's it's I don't think I'm doing
good job promoting because it's not it's
not genuine let's face it right yeah
right so day to day still like running
every day is pretty much you know front
and center like walk me through a
typical day in the life when you're not
traveling and doing these other various
things that you do yeah so yesterday I
had a day like a day off and I'm getting
ready to go do a bunch of big races
uh-huh so I just got up at about not
really like 7 a.m. put on a hydration
pack and took off
yeah and ran about 50 55 miles I was
gone all day what do you map that out
and plan like you say okay this is what
I'm gonna do today or do you just head
out and make a decision on the fly like
I feel good I'm gonna go further or you
know just kind of like feel into
yourself like how does that work ya know
yesterday I wanted to do a long training
run and I thought let's just see how far
you can go before you feel like you're
actually damaging yourself like how far
can you push and still think it's
training not like big recovery afterward
right and that just seemed to be the
spot so I know wanted to run over to the
beach you've been to my place so it's
it's an overcast in some Beach I wanted
to go see the coast did that and just
felt kind of good and it's not it wasn't
a fast run rich I mean it's not like I'm
breaking speed records it was a good
long training run I walked a lot on the
uphills you know shuffle along a lot and
ran pretty hard some of the downhills
and just showed back home for dinner
after sunset and what are the races that
you're getting ready for I'm going back
to Greece to do this race ball this
bathroom spartathlon which is 153 mile
race from Athens to Sparta and then I'm
going to fly to Australia from Greece to
run the black all 100 in Queensland on
the Sunshine Coast
I don't know that race I it's amazing
it's on the Sunshine Coast of Australia
okay no do that yeah yeah so back to
back wow that's exciting and why go back
to spartathlon just because that's your
home turf yeah I mean I feel so
comfortable in Greece like I almost feel
like it's I feel more at home in Greece
sometimes than they do here and that
race has so much lore involved and
people want me to come back
you know I'm doing a speaking gig and
they're giving me an award and so I I
just can't let that's always good yeah
right well it was like bad water I mean
you know I've got a different crew this
year and I get to experience it through
other people's eyes it's almost like
having a child like everything's are
fresh like you went out to Death Valley
with me right and you were just you were
amazed by it I mean I could see how you
were taken aback and it was all new and
to me that's exciting because I've been
there ten times right ten doctrine eight
other people's it was it was we haven't
talked about that like I think bad water
took place after the last time you were
on the podcast I think what year was
that see we are older what year was that
bad where it was that was that 2017 I
think it was earlier in that I think is
maybe 16 well let's recap it because it
was an incredible experience for me I
mean first of all like I was honored
that you asked me to help crew for you I
was delighted to be able to show up for
you and it was an experience like I've
never seen before I I knew it was a
really hard race perhaps one of the
hardest races out there but man it was
really something being there step by
step with you throughout the way and I
remember there's a couple vivid memories
that I have about that experience one of
which is when I arrived I asked coupe
you're who we're gonna talk about let's
talk about doing a crazy thing you know
what keeps doing right okay talk about
that I was like so like what's teens
like how we doing this like I just
figured like it a lot of these ultras
the runners running and then you kind of
paste the person in the last 25% of it
but mostly they're out there and you're
just feeding them as they come by or
you're leapfrogging with the van and and
Jason's like oh he wants someone to run
with him the whole time and I literally
turned he turned white I was like wait
what the entire time cuz it wasn't like
I trained I hadn't been training that
much at that point I hadn't thought that
much about what I was getting involved
in I just said I'm gonna be handing him
water bottles and then when the reality
dawned on me of what you know how taxing
this was actually gonna be I got
terrified and I remember
I think it was my first legit pull with
you and it was in the mid to late
afternoon I think we were coming through
stovepipe wells it was the hottest part
of the day and I was just I was my heart
rate was like a hundred and seventy
running like ten thirty miles or
something like that yeah and I had to
get chase I was like I got a pull I ran
with you for like an hour and you were
pulling away from me I couldn't keep
pace and I was like Jason you got to
relieve me and I was thinking all I was
thinking was I'm gonna be the only crew
member who's gonna end up in the medical
tent this is not a good look
no it actually happens more often than
not that a crew end up in the hospital
versus runners because they're looking
after like you or you're looking after
me like hey I got a support Dean you
might not be thinking about yourself
right I remember you hop it on the car
you don't have a hat on or anything I
mean oh god this rich world guys know
hardcore I'm shirtless prepared and now
I'm remembering we did talk about this
because when it came to that I did a
long pole with you in the evening we
went like most of the night and a lot of
that was walking cuz it was uphill and
you were telling me all about the book
that you were working on the road to
Sparta so and that obviously came out
later yeah
I felt better during that point and we
were also I believe David Goggins was
right on your tail for most of that day
and everybody knows how that guy's blown
up and as part of the mainstream
consciousness now yeah in a really cool
way which is great to see and that was a
that was not an easy race for you you
were struggling you had a hard time it
certainly wasn't your best performance
but another vivid memory was just how
gracious and kind you were throughout
the entire experience like not one gruff
moment not one you know petulant
outburst the entire time I'm a good
drunk pressed by that well it's like
it's like going drinking with someone
you know you you think you know someone
and a couple shots tequila in you see
different side of me like all of its not
the person I thought they were I'm a
happy drunk when when I'm out there just
beat to [ __ ] as it was during bad water
yeah it's all good yeah
yeah I mean when you're for people that
don't know when you're doing an ultra
like that just it brings you it brings
out the best and the worst in people
because you're so stripped down like
you're just so raw so it's not uncommon
Eli kever have your friends crew for you
because you know the dark side of people
comes out when all they're you know sort
of veneer is stripped away and I was
just in it just it spoke to me deeply
about what kind of person you are in
your character and then I remember when
the race was complete we went back to
the hotel and you were so why feel like
I can't go to dinner like I'm just
wrecked like I've no I don't remember
ever feeling this wracked from a race
like I don't know what do you like I
don't know what's going on I'm like dude
you just ran what do you mean you don't
know what's going on you're like I can't
go to dinner I'm so sorry I'm like don't
worry about it so we all go to dinner we
come back we go to sleep we wake up the
next morning and the amazing thing about
bad water is the little strip of hotels
in the main town is right along the core
so you wake up in the morning and you
see people still coming in in your man
and you woke up and you said I feel
great I'm gonna go running like a new
person
I don't know what happened but I feel
totally fine now well I mean and and to
your point about being gracious I mean
think about it
I finished we went back I got a good
night's sleep there are people still out
there running and we saw them in the
morning and they're still running I mean
they're out there for so long I have
nothing you know I'm complaining it's
taking me 32 hours mm-hmm you know
because I've run it much faster than
that but you know the the the broader
picture is that I finished bad water
right and to anyone that's a huge
accomplishment of course yeah of course
and it's so uplifting and inspirational
to see
I mean imagine being out there for
another 15 hours like how hard that's
gotta be on you and the Koran your crew
and everyone it's just insane I think
you know if you're looking if anyone
listening this once it's just a
life-changing experience I would say
just go spectator bad water uh-huh are
you right I mean you you don't it's
about as far away from Earth as you can
get and still be on earth yeah yeah and
so after that year they change they
changed the course you
there were some national park like
changing of the guard but now they're
back to the original course I think
right back to the original course the
only difference is it's now a night
start so the National Parks makes them
run it at night because they're you're
not allowed to have a race in
temperatures above 120 degrees what
attorney came up with that hard mark
yeah I don't know so there Chris the the
race directors like well if we start at
night hopefully it'll cool down but you
know 120 when we start there's somebody
monitoring that because it definitely
gets up to 130 it does in the middle of
the day you know there's that baby at
the starter camp tip out of them yeah
the first wave I think goes out at 6
p.m. and then 8 p.m. and then 10 p.m. so
it's the cool of the night yeah it's
like 115 changes it it does cuz you're
running through stovepipe wells like
you're running through the middle of
Death Valley at night it's a different
experience yeah yeah it's not quite this
I would have been better for me so Jason
coop
who was your crew captain that year and
he kind of coaches you a little bit like
I don't know if that's still the case
but you guys oh yeah no I buried or
whatever he's more like a mentor at this
point yeah I mean he's just a wealth of
endurance wisdom and he's gotten back
into racing and so right now he's in the
midst of doing this insane race that I'd
never heard of called tort against tore
the Giants because it's insane this race
it's in Italy and basically you traverse
like all the highest peaks in the Alps
you have a like a week to do it it's 205
miles and over that 205 miles you have
80,000 feet of elevation game and you
can it's not a stage race like you just
however long you need to do to get it
done you get up to like I don't know six
days or something like that 150 hours I
told you to use every single second are
you following the race what's going on
over this I haven't I I saw Twitter that
he was doing pretty well after like the
first day and a half or something like
that but I don't know do you know like
there's been insane snowstorms I heard
yesterday these snow flurries and yeah
Wow yeah and you just you have to bring
all your stuff and you just sleep on the
side of the trail whenever you feel like
it or how does that work
there's they call I don't think they
call them aid stations that come life
support stations every life support
right every 50k
yeah it's 31 miles someone's saying well
you know you just has to cover 31 miles
you can sleep in a hut I'm like you know
do you hear how would you elevate you
only like 15,000 feet of elevation no
and it's snow flurries it's yeah start
crunching the math and it's you know
it's tough how many people do that
I think there's over 100 people I looked
I kind of looked through the roster and
I think there's over 100 it's mostly
Europeans like who was one the few
Americans yeah huh it'll be interesting
to see I hope you may be he's been I've
been following him on strawberries been
put it he put in some really big days no
entry though yeah yeah yeah wild man
yeah surprised you haven't done that one
yeah no I I tell my family like hold me
in check yeah don't it's so easy when
you look online right just hit enter
just hit register little button right
there like hold my hand back yeah that's
once you're in you're in
so one thing we haven't talked about is
your Silk Road adventure yeah so talk to
me about how that came together and what
that experience was like so I was
contacted by the State Department to be
a US athlete ambassador and it was
actually John Kerry when he was in the
State Department he was a big cyclist
and he said I have this idea that I'd
like to celebrate 25 years of diplomatic
relations between who's Becky Stan
Kyrgyzstan and Kazakhstan by linking the
three together on the ancient Silk Road
the ancient Silk Road passes through all
three countries and he said I was gonna
try and cycle it but it's just there's
it's not gonna work out what do you
think about running it so it was 525
kilometer run between who's Becky Stan
Kyrgyzstan and Kazakhstan and I was a
diplomat so I had like diplomatic
obligations the entire way it was really
bizarre experience what were those
obligations I spoke at embassies I spoke
at schools I spoke at municipalities
yeah so every day you'd run a certain
amount and then you have some kind of
something on the schedule where you'd
have to go talk to people rich I don't
know how to describe what I went through
I mean I
yeah exactly I mean you're back in like
the time of Genghis Khan through parts
of this terrain or what amount and it
was in July so it was like it was about
a hundred and ten degrees the first day
and I ran across who's back east and so
it's like a desert back he stands right
above Afghanistan uh-huh
and I pull into town and I'm wrecked
I've run about 50 miles there's no ice
in our van the crew is all Russian they
don't speak English
they've never crewed for a run of these
think I'm crazy yeah up there running
and I pull in the town there's about
5,000 people along with the roadway like
they said when they briefed me they said
the entire town is gonna come out these
people have never seen an American
before right and here I come running
down the road like Forrest Gump
literally high-fiving people and no one
speaks English and I was because Becky
so I can't understand a word they're
saying I come into the main square
there's a traditional dance going on
there's music playing the mayor's there
and they said when you get into town
they're gonna have a feast for you
because it's a nomadic culture so they
greet people they're gonna they're gonna
want you to try everything so I pull in
and there's enough food there for 30
people I mean it is a huge spread of
food and you're gonna love this one
thing one of the mainstays there is
horse meat so they hand me a plate of
horse meat and you know you're in front
of 3,000 people what do you do right and
you eat some horse Wow and then they
handed me this bowl of traditional drink
and it looked like a half a coconut
imagine a coconut sewed in half and
there was white inside to it look like
coconut milk I thought well it's
something refreshing so 110 degrees 50
miles I'm gonna drink something cool and
refreshing I drink this stuff and it's
called kumis it's fermented mares milk
so it's horse milk that's been fermented
and it tastes like drinking Parmesan
cheese I mean it was just the heaviest
most fermented was it alcoholic it was
slightly alcoholic it tasted like
drinking sour cream literally like
drinking sour cream and I was gonna gag
and there's 5,000 people looking at me
you know the mayor you kind of and I you
know with the smiles of approval like
this is our traditional drink what do
you think
oh my god what does he think horse me
like I can't imagine well for you
non-vegans it was pretty good actually
lean and yeah was that in the middle of
the run or we had you concluded the run
for the day that was the end of the day
and then I went to a big dinner that
night with a bunch of dignitaries you
know it was like that bad water thing
where I'm just you know dead and I'm
putting on a suit yeah you know going
out to dinner with a bunch of
dignitaries yeah and how how many miles
a day were you doing for that I would do
about 40 to 50 miles a day yeah yeah and
just we and people would run I probably
had 10,000 people run with me some like
the military guys that come out and run
with me school kids has run with me we
had a couple of organized runs and it
was it was really a phenomenal
experience you know passing through some
of the villages obviously you know in
the back countries they're not runners I
mean you know they're more nomadic and
they just thought it was the funniest
you know this guy running down the road
right now they probably lived there
their entire lives generations have they
probably haven't seen a single runner
and here's this American guy you know
this colorful outfit just running down
the road waving at him well you you open
up this new book running for good with a
story from that experience maybe tell us
did your homework like the opening its
the opening chapter of the book but it's
a great story I think it encapsulates a
lot about you know the theme of the book
which is running for good like about
community and and you know connection
yeah well I'm Kyrgyzstan has mountain
peaks like series mountain peaks like
20k mountain peaks so I was running up
in the mountains one day in the
snowstorm like sleet hail rain came in
and I was totally unprepared and as I
was running along the road I'm starting
to get hypothermia like my fingers were
blue all the things that happen to you
when you're doing high thermia and there
was a there was a yurt on the side of
the road and I could see smoke coming
out of it and I saw like a face kind of
come out the door and look at me and I
kind of looked at this person and I kind
of waved and then I saw a little couple
kids come out like what's going on
what's what's up there and these kids
came out and got me and they said come
on date like they just grabbed me by the
hand and brought me down because I was
walking at this point just shiver
and they had hot tea inside and they
gave me hot tea they had blank they put
these wool blankets over me
it was a yurt right yeah you're right
nobody goes knowing no ability to
verbally communicate and they must have
thought it was a Martian I mean they're
looking at I'm in colorful running game
right right out in the middle they've
never seen in Karastan yeah they'll own
a runner yeah and and so like how how
did you you know communicate with that
like did were they able to kind of
understand what you were trying to do
just laughter and no I said like the
names of the cities right and you're
kind of like right yes do you get
Bishkek because they need the name of
the city and they looked at me like why
you know does he need a ride or what you
know how's he gonna get there and that
kind went like this just did the running
you know arm swing kind of thing and
they kind of looked at me like they got
it like right Jesus this guy's gonna run
the Bishkek and you had you have crew
waiting for you at destinations along
the way like if they can't get over the
mountain like how does that work yeah or
not work yeah yeah and that was another
thing there was it was Russian so the
language barrier was incredible the
first day I came running into this van
again it's 110 degrees in Uzbekistan and
it's this van that's horrible for
crewing it's got it doesn't have a
sliding door like it's you know regular
regular door so I'm like going in and
out of the passenger side trying to get
into this van it's just 200 degrees in
this van filled with flies no ice and
all these Russian guys what they would
do they pull up to the crew spot that
stop they just huddle down in the shade
of the van and they'd start smoking oh
so I'd run up to this van with just
secondhand smoke and I tried to you know
eventually tell them no no cigarettes
and they there at the end they were
running with me like little spurts and
they you know they weren't smoke and
they're really respectful yeah you know
I got to him you John Kerry you couldn't
get like an American crew or some some
guys that know what they're doing to
come out with you or was this just a
budget thing
no there was I had one like handler and
he was great but he was we were
overwhelmed rich we got thrown in this
thing and it just kind of took on a life
of its own there were so many variables
to manage along with the meat like we
had a media person with us yeah
manage all these moving parts was just
overwhelming I mean he couldn't he just
finally just was paralyzed yeah I saw
some short little video clips of it but
did you like did you capture enough to
do like a mini documentary or anything
like that from this you know the content
that was captured is amazing it was it
was a this Russian videographer and he
did a really good job and he spoke
English and all of the clips are still
on the State Department website so it's
all there yeah and what did you like I
mean those that part of the world is so
foreign for Americans we have a sense of
what we think it might be like but what
is the reality you know what did you
learn about those cultures like Pete you
know literally boots on the ground you
know to be honest I don't know we have
it so good here in America materially
we're wealthier they are happier people
they are just happier people like every
family matters you right I never saw one
Starbucks one McDonald's I never heard
of any I heard one British couple
speaking but other than that I heard no
English
the people are more respectful of each
other they look at each other they say
thank you they're you know they're
they're happier they're just generally
happier the kids are smiling and
laughing I mean when you get into the
cities you know as usual there's traffic
and honking and all that kind of stuff
but overall I would say it's just not as
aggressive it's a it's a it's a gentler
place to be mm-hmm yeah yeah we always
hear these stories time and time again
you know people that travel to places
off the grid and they come back and
they're like they're happier they don't
have anything but they're happy they go
to India and you know people are missing
limbs but they're laughing and yeah and
and we have this sense of how can we
take some of that and incorporate it
into our lives and then there's like a
half-life on that sensibility it seems
to just you know kind of fade away and
we're just back to doing what we're
doing
arguing with somebody star and everyone
is doing it around you it's hard to keep
like you you get a sense like if I'm not
doing it I'm missing out like I'm gonna
fall behind or be irrelevant if I'm not
tweeting constantly mm-hmm they don't
have that feeling there's not that
anxiety and I think we all feel it here
really and especially with social media
there's just constant pressure it's
constant and you really have to be
disciplined to step away from that and
just say well [ __ ] it I don't care I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna respond to
people today mm-hmm I think you're
you're learning that would you say well
I think you know it's a it's a weird
relationship that I have to all of this
stuff like I love what I do but it also
you know it can encroach on the other
things that I enjoy doing and it's been
such a gift that this show has grown and
impacts so many people and I feel a
responsibility to that and and there is
a joy to it as well like there's there's
a few things I'd rather be doing right
now than sitting down and talking to you
it's like it doesn't it's not it doesn't
feel like work to me but there's a whole
lot of other stuff that goes into trying
to create something great that impacts
other people and that gives me a sense
of fulfillment but it can also you know
become overwhelming at times and and I
have to remind myself like oh I you know
I asked for this like this is you know I
want it I want to be grateful I'm not
always grateful like this is the life
that I wanted and now it's all happening
but how do I manage it all and make sure
that my my finger is on the pulse of the
things that are most important and that
those things are not you know being
ignored or falling by the wayside and
that can you know it gets hard and and
social media isn't is an aspect of that
like I use it to amplify the message of
what we're doing here but I also can
catch myself scrolling mindlessly you
know so there's a difference between
using it for a purpose and having sort
of a detached objectivity about it
versus you know using it addictively and
in a consumptive way mm-hmm and you know
I don't know how to strike that balance
but you seem to have figured it out like
you have somebody else who handles all
that stuff for you I think you did at
one point I don't know what you're doing
now now I kind of do myself people they
kind of caught on to it they like hate
or lie it's not your voice well no yeah
they know they know they absolutely know
and authenticity is important I think
and and so if that means you're not
posting is as much
so be it yeah no one's going anywhere
you're living your life everyone knows
you're out on the trail running fifty
five miles to and from Stinson Beach
yeah don't wait Wow
you know I'm probably like do I get some
really personal messages I mean runners
feel a connection and people confide in
me in ways that is like I can't step
away from it like you know you I get
these messages I'm like Jesus really
went through that and I started like in
your running because you read my book
how do you not respond to that I can't
like and that happens all the time and
it's just I can't walk away from it I
feel like a connection with this person
and I feel like I owe them to respond
just a human connection and that's fine
once in a while but when you're getting
like you know 15 20 of those messages a
day you can't respond no but where do
you draw the line it's the thing once I
read something like that I'm so engaged
it's like alright I'm gonna spend 20
minutes at least you know crafting a
nice response yeah to what they're
saying and other questions and
everything else yeah I mean it's a it's
a gift to get those and it's a reminder
of the why behind what it is that you do
and I think for a lot of those people
there it's their way of giving you a
gift for what you've already given them
I don't necessarily think that you owe
them like some super long response like
I think a lot of them they're probably
surprised if you respond like wow you
actually responded like they don't have
an expectation for the most part it's
just their way of thanking you for the
books that you've written in the work
that you do and and you know another
thing that that was palpable about you
know me kind of tagging along with you
at badwater is I wash you in real-time
navigate that like we go to the you know
the banquet before the thing you know
there's all this stuff around the race
and all these people want a minute of
your time and you were very conscious of
making sure that you were present for
each of those exchanges you know
sometimes at the sacrifice of your own
well-being in preparation for the race
that you're about to run right like
you're you're willing to allow that to
tax you to a certain degree because
that's the job it is and thankfully to
your point it's part of my nature so I I
just I am a giving person and
it's it's genuine when I like make some
sack personal sacrifices for the
betterment of someone else that gives me
fulfillment I got to be honest and you
know these messages I get that say I
inspire people they it goes both ways
right I mean I get incredibly inspired
by people telling me that I inspire them
I'm not sure how I inspire them but you
know it like gives me a sense of purpose
almost like what I'm doing matters you
know 100 percent yeah a hundred percent
I mean when you wrote the first book
ultramarathon man the state of
ultrarunning was very different from
what it is today yeah and and you know
you're partially responsible for this
massive explosion of interest in people
pushing their their limits and their
boundaries in various ways and in
creative new ways we're always seeing
new crazy races popping up all over the
place and people are really engaged by
this world in a in a way that didn't
exist when you like you really helped
put this on the map like do you look
back on that and think wow look what
look what's happened since that moment
well I know the first year I ran an
ultra was 1993 and in North America
there are 3,500 finishers of an ultra
last year there were 115,000 finishers
so the growth has been insane yeah and
yeah I feel you know conflicted
sometimes you have like western states
the odds of getting into western states
now are less than the odds of getting
into Harvard right literally there was
something like 15,000 applications for
369 it's always fixed at 369 mhm
I mean it's impossible if people are
like I've tried for 10 years I can't get
into western states so you know that has
kind of been a downside but damn you
Dean corn is so popular well there's
there's such a hardcore you know
sensibility you know with the the tried
and true community like this was a
community that it was just about the
love they're sleeping in tents at the
start line there's ten people there's no
fanfare there's nothing and there's a
there's something beautiful about that
the the purism of that that I think gets
lost at some of these huge races like
UTMB or western states but there's still
so many other races that are still very
much like that and it's still you know I
go to western states and I think this is
not the Superbowl I mean everyone's like
wow this is the biggest thing ever and
is still very grassroots I mean finishes
in a high school Stadium you know it's
still - you know - people are just
getting into the sport it is fresh and
new and novel and it's you know three
million people ran a 5k in North America
last year so the numbers of runners
running an ultra still a very very small
percentage of what all runners and it's
still very fresh and new to a lot of
people you know the route this sports
tells a lot of room for growth yeah well
one of the things I know that's been in
the back of your mind for a long time
and we've talked about it in the past is
this ambitious goal that you have of
running a marathon and every call 203
countries and and when is this gonna
happen
come on people say do you ever fail I'm
like I'm in charge area on the phone
yeah these visa issues or whatever it is
that's holding you back
that is an ambitious plan that's killing
me but I've been failing for seven years
and I what slow what it what is the big
roadblock here is it just it's missions
in certain places no I've got the plan I
think I can get the permission it's just
lining up the sponsorship you know the
money to pull it off and all of that for
the right cause at the same time it's
just that everything's got to be aligned
perfectly well all you fortune 500 CEOs
out there listening yeah yeah this is a
Dina call let's make this let's get this
thing going already yeah and it's gonna
take a global brand right that's another
thing I mean if you know if you're a
domestic brand you might want to sponsor
the US tour but it's one marathon in the
US so it's gonna have to be a global
brand that's really invested in this
right yeah so getting permission to go
to places like North Korea and like
you've got that sorted out there's a the
State Department has a list of countries
where I can't leave the airport sort of
like you can set up a treadmill you can
have a shred know set up in the airport
but you're not leaving the airport like
we can't get you out of the airport and
that list is kind of dynamic as you know
it's global things change yeah
so what's going on with this
relationship with the State Department
I'm sorry I think you're maybe you're
some kind of
some kind of spy they just catch you to
all these these places I'll he's running
but actually he's collecting anything
it's been an interesting relationship
that's a different world that that whole
yeah what goes on there is a little bit
different and I can't I can't talk about
yeah yeah being tight-lipped I don't
know I'm gonna spin a conspiracy yarn I
think you're an attorney they make you
signs through [ __ ] well you mentioned
that that uh you just ran was it
yesterday fifty five miles yeah I mean
you look fresh as a daisy what is the
what is the you know has as you start to
age have you had to change your recovery
routine do you still bounce back like
you always have or like what is it what
does it look like how is it evolved you
know one thing I'm not doing is setting
an alarm anymore so I'm trying to wake
naturally whenever I can so you know I
plug for having this interview in the
afternoon because it gives you the whole
morning to kind of just regroup so I
don't set an alarm like before I used to
sleep for maybe five hours a night and
the alarm and wake me up now I just
sometimes I only sleep four or five
hours other nights I sleep nine or ten
hours and I'm fine with that so I'm not
I'm just letting myself wake up
naturally that's helped a lot just you
know purity of diet continuing to refine
my diet intermittent fasting you know
all the things that are kind of in vogue
right now yeah I've been doing that for
fifteen years yeah and I never sit down
rich that's why I'm surprised we're
sitting here this is yeah yeah sacrilege
would you want to stand okay we have
these really cool ergonomic stools
though that actually is pretty
comfortable okay it's far as sitting
this is a good one yeah yeah I mean one
of the things I read is is you know
there's a lot of you know we can go down
the rabbit hole I'm like how long you
know after you train are you supposed to
eat and what do you eat and how do you
how do you you know make sure that
you're accelerating that recovery
process enhancing it as much as possible
so you can bounce back day to day one of
the things that that I know that you do
that I've experimented with that I think
is very valuable and doesn't get talked
about very much is actually you go out
of your way to like not do those things
because that provide
it's an added stress on the body and an
adaptive response that ultimately will
make you stronger if you're doing it
right so rather than I have to replenish
right after my run like maybe let's not
do that for a while what will happen if
I don't do that I wait a couple more
hours or I wait until dinner or
something like that
maybe I'm not as fresh the next day but
long-term is this gonna make me stronger
I agree I agree some and I also think
that not only with diet but you know
coming home from a long hard run when
you're hot you just want to hop in the
pool right or just hop in the shower I
always say don't do it stay miserable
just walk around in a miserable State
and a hot you know your shoes are tight
everything is miserable ride that out
because your body's going to adapt to it
don't just immediately you know let that
go and make yourself comfortable stay
uncomfortable for as long as you can
sometimes I get back from like a long
ride or a run and just because I got
kids and responsibilities you know like
I'll just be in my bib shorts for like
four more hours because I'm you know
helping out or doing whatever needs to
get to work or sitting at my computer
and I was like I should probably shower
at some point you know yeah I think
Sharon
I haven't eaten yes overrated yeah yeah
it's not that overrated I think it is I
don't know yeah so inner what does the
intermittent fasting look like it's
typically you know dinner and then maybe
all the way to dinner the next day
uh-huh but a lot of times late afternoon
you know maybe like I haven't eaten
anything today I got up I do drink
coffee I love coffee so I had a cup of
coffee and I'm fasting right now I'm
probably when I get back home yeah so is
that is that something you plan out or
you just kind of feel it out and do it
once in a while or is that like an
everyday thing uh it's I listen to my
body as much as I can so it's you know
sometimes it's hard to fast because you
know you just want to chew off the back
of your hand you're so hungry yeah and
if that's the case I'll eat something
but now I don't you know I can go easily
I think people too often say oh I've
gotta eat I gotta eat I'm gonna die I
got to eat you really don't have to eat
it if you cannot you know if you can
withhold eating for half an hour maybe
have a glass of water you get beyond it
yeah
I've gotten to the point where it's
really not that difficult to just eat
only dinner
yeah and train during the day like I
went at the pool today I put in five
thousand I haven't eaten anything today
I feel completely fine part of that I
think is is after doing this kind of
stuff for so many years and you've
talked about this a lot like you just
become very adapted to it you're very
efficient at it you you're this
fat-burning machine like your body is so
is so used to these activities that
they're just not that taxing they're not
as taxing as they would be to somebody
who's newer to these kinds of pursuits
and I think it does it does fly in the
face of that idea like oh you got to eat
you know three meals a day like I don't
know who came up with that but I think
the danger comes in with a lot of people
who can develop eating disorders around
this stuff and I think you know in the
endurance community it's not immune from
a lot of people who can hide behind oh
I'm intermittent fasting or I'm doing
this or this diet or that diet when they
have a very unhealthy relationship to
food so you know I think people have to
be really honest with themselves about
what their motivations are I agree and I
think you can look at people and tell I
think you can look at their nails see if
their nails are healthy if their hair is
really brittle you can tell if someone
you know it's gone beyond healthy diet
into something extreme and I think when
you look at me I'm a pretty healthy guy
you know it's not like I don't think
it's it's too extreme I don't you know I
don't I don't stress about not eating
like I can't eat if I want to eat and I
can go without it if I want to go
without it yeah I like that that so when
you're when you're going out for your 55
miles and you put on the hydration pack
what do you bring with you
you know I discovered this stuff called
the Muir energy and have you seen your
energy their little packets it's they
make the best nut butters ever so it's
primarily nut butters so it's kind of
keto yeah and then water as well or any
kind of electrolyte or no I just drink
water along the way sometimes yeah just
water
yeah Brian water I carry em a handheld
with my with my hydration pack so I've
got a lot of water on me and what's the
like longest that you'll go out when you
don't bring a pack or anything with you
like it's just you're just going out
without a shirt on or whatever I'll do a
marathon marathon yeah yes yeah uh-huh
I kind of like that feeling cuz you're
really you're really really struggling
to get to the get home yeah at that
point well I would urge everybody out
there to be cautious about that and work
their way up to it but I do think that
you know when you're out on the trails
and you see people that you know are
only going out for their 10k or whatever
five miles or something like that who
are just loaded loaded to bare with
backpacks that are just filled with like
you know enough food to feed a family of
four on a picnic on the fourth of July
and you're like what are you doing on
that go for it tell me preach it well I
mean I still I still do a lot like I can
still go to a 5k and I'm kind of a thing
like people know who I am even though
they're not hardcore runners even half
marathon and you see these people at the
start of a half marathon and their
hydration belt is just filled with you
know thirty gels definitely gonna throw
up if you eat them all they think they
need them they think well I got to have
so many calories before I start you know
people still think they have to have
pancakes in the morning before a race
and they still think they got a pasta
load so there's still a lot of myths out
there with people mm-hmm
yeah I mean you've you've evolved quite
a bit from the days of ordering a pizza
while you're out there running to you
know what you're doing now well I mean I
was in I pasta I mean I carbo loaded I'm
sure you were kind of in that phase
every about the same and that was the
thing to do right you just load up on
carbs and I remember just standing at
the start of a race feeling so bloated
in the morning at the start because I
ate so much pasta the night before and I
thought something's just not right like
I don't need to do this to my body
mmm and now it's more of a low carb
approach that you know a much more local
and lower fibers well like before big
race I really watch especially insoluble
fiber you know there's soluble there's
two types of fiber insoluble fiber and
the stuff that passes right through you
I try to cut back on that a few days
before race obviously all that yeah
that's that has an impact on how many
times you gotta jump on the trail and
pull the pants down all right
well yeah thank you to grab a rich
listen anybody he's you know been out on
trails
you know trail running is how about
experience no I ran a I ran a 50k the
weekend before last and I remember
coming in to pan toll station there's a
PlayStation there and there's a bunch of
people a car no hey how's it going
and let us turn up and say where's the
bathroom yeah I'd say it goes so bad and
they're you know and then I came out of
like I'm so sorry to say hi to anyone I
just went took a big dump and they're
like hey it's an ultra this is what you
do this is that's the deal yeah you know
I mean that goes with the territory
that's that's part of every runners been
there right yeah yeah well let's talk
about this book running for good this is
your fourth book this is my second
collaboration with the Chicken Soup for
the Soul humble and I've done another
one yep this is the second running book
and this is if you count Chicken Soup
for the Soul this is my sixth book Wow
so well maybe let's start with talking
about like the Chicken Soup for the Soul
situation all together like how did that
come together you know I when I was
actually in graduate school one of my
professors said you guys have to read
this Chicken Soup for the Soul book I
think it was original one that came out
he's like it'll ground you it was like
required reading Wow that's good yeah
this is business school I was an MBA and
I was like why are we reading this and I
was so enamored with these stories so
the concept of Chicken Soup for the Soul
is there books are a hundred and one
short stories by 101 different
contributors so it's 101 people that
write about being a human and whatever
the topic is about and it's kind of
voyeurism like you see into someone
else's life they kind of confess and
about you know three or four pages some
episode of their life mm-hmm and it was
really powerful I thought they've got
something here you know obviously
they've sold I think 500 million copies
crazy yeah so I mean they obviously it's
it it works and when they came to me and
said let's do something about running I
thought you know this this is gonna be
great because my books you know you both
of our books we're kind of it's a
different audience that we appeal to
it's not the everyday athlete right it's
um you know a little more elite sort of
thing and this really was a book that
was not just for runners but for
right walkers as well and so I thought
this is a great way to help spread the
message get more you know kind of in
vandalize the benefits of running and
walking yeah what was the first one you
did with them it was just called Chicken
Soup for the Soul on running mmm was
just a running book and then you just
put to get you like collated a whole
bunch of stories yeah yeah we get and
like we had for this book running for
good so the theme of this one is how is
running but good to your life and we
know what right you know that could be
through a charity run it could be
through losing hundreds of pounds it
could be through overcoming PTSD through
running so it's created good in your
life and that's the focus of this book
we received about I think 1500
submissions and again it's a hundred one
story so it was it was really hard to go
through and you know curate and write
and you know determine which ones made
the final cut
well what's great is that it allows you
to continue telling stories about
running without making it about like all
right I've written a whole bunch of
books about this yeah let's let a few
other people well when you're indoors
yeah you're both kind of memorable about
how many memoirs can you write yes and
it's great yeah there's the there
there's all it's all different kinds of
people from all different walks of life
yeah who all have their version of how
running has improved their lives and
also good being defined broadly to me
not just good in my own life meaning the
storyteller but also how can you use
running to leverage good for others
right yeah sort of like you know
versions of your running a Silk Road
yeah and it's you know I'm I think a
little more immersed in that world than
then you might be just because I do a
lot of like group events like you know
fun runs with groups and it's it's a
great experience I mean I'm a very much
an introvert I think like you so I
prefer running on my own you know for 55
miles by myself and the you know and the
trails and we're in but you know
spending an hour with you know 30 or 40
you know 100 fired-up runners that are
just getting into it it really it just
it it grounds you it gives you a better
broader perspective on running like now
everyone runs you know in the mountains
in Moran or 300 mountain you know 300
kilometers in Europe I mean a lot of
people for them to finish a half
marathon is its undoable like a Killian
yeah I just did Jesse it's lers 29 0 29
event yeah and actually you were the
person who first introduced me to Jesse
that way back in the day I do yeah and
he's become a friend he's great and and
that event was magical for many reasons
but profound mostly because of what you
just said like most of the people that
were doing this event hadn't done very
many hard kind of athletic things in
their lives these are like everyday
people business people or whatever and
unlike a 5k that's gonna be done you
know in a half an hour or an hour or
whatever depending upon your speed yeah
this thing like on paper it's like well
you walk up a mountain you take the
gauntlet down like how hard can it be
yeah but it was really hard it was hard
for me and my group of hardcore friends
like every every ascent back down was
like you know close to two hours so yeah
and it was 13 times so yeah you had to
do it I mean that's 26 hours right there
and these are people who've never done
anything like this and it was amazing
how many of them just committed 100%
went all through the night didn't sleep
like just just did everything in their
power to dig as deep as possible to get
it done whether that meant doing all 13
or doing 10 or doing six or whatever and
I got more inspiration from those people
then from anything that I've witnessed
or experienced recently it was amazing
and what was great is there's no there's
no leaderboard they don't he doesn't
like you know track time or place or
anything like that and at the banquet
it's just about highlighting a couple
people who you know really got outside
themselves to you know exceed their
perceived limits like one guy who had
done for the year before and had lost a
bunch of weight and then did ten and a
65 year old woman who like got all
thirteen done right down to the wire
like it was super cool to do that so it
inspired me to
to try to expand my horizons to like I
am an introvert like I'm not like crazy
about all the group stuff like I do it
all the time and it's like no man you
know being around all those people but I
got so much out of it that I want to
explore being part of that
what's and it's funny you bring that up
because just yesterday I got an email
from a guy from Singapore that had come
over to do that event and he's like that
was incredible it was your book he sent
me a photo of my book he's like your
book inspired me to like explore this
world and I just finished the same thing
you just finished Wow yeah that's pretty
cool yeah but I mean to that point you
know western states more people come out
it's got a 30 hour cutoff more people
come out the last hour yeah to watch the
last finishers then are there for the
winner a lot more so more people are
inspired by seeing can they make it in
30 hours yes a human drama of watching
someone come onto a track with 30
seconds left you know after running
99.99 miles just saying come on you can
get there you can get there it's crazy
yeah there was a there was a situation
like that at that the 29:29 thing there
was a guy who had done 12 and he was at
the summit and there was like I don't
know an hour and 45 minutes left and
yeah you know he was like he was hurting
and I think his fastest round trip was
like two and a half hours something like
that yeah and mark Jesse's partner was
like well this guy was like I'm done
well there's no way I was not enough
time for me to do another one it marks
like come on dude
the clock still ticking you got time get
on that gondola go down and and get it
done and he was like okay and then
everybody's dead now but everybody
rallied to like support this guy so many
people who had already finished went
down on the course to help bring him up
yeah and there was a cheering section
like Bar None at the top and literally
he had like thirty Seconds to make it
across the finish line before the
36-hour cutoff and about a hundred yards
from the line he like stumbled and I
thought who's gonna pass out and it was
like it's like ten nine and he got up
and he literally somehow got himself
across the finish line
I don't know how he did it and it was
remarkable he made it so awesome to see
that and that's the kind of thing that
you see time and time again I'm sure you
see it all the time at all of these
events that you go to it ya know those
and those those sort of moments or
magical aren't ya yeah there's something
about it and these are kind of the
stories that are there in this book
right yes and you know there's another
there's another element that people
don't really think about is their
spectators they come out to watch races
like I I finished New York City Marathon
last year you know I've done it I know
probably seven hundred thousand times
yeah and I'm walking back you know it's
just one of those New York things I'm
walking back to my hotel and I started
talking to a woman who congratulated me
and I said you know did you have a
runner in the race and she said no I
said what were you doing she's like I'm
I'm just with spectating I'm like you
just came out to cheer what did you
think's together well I've done it for
the last 20 years like you just come out
like it's the best day of my life like
there's something about watching these
people and their persistence and how
hard they have it and just it just it
makes me filled with life I never
thought about that like I would never
think to go watch a running race for
what you get as expected she wasn't a
runner mm-hmm she just said it's
something about the human drama that
pulls you in yeah yeah I think that that
speaks to the broader inspiration not
just like a lot of this is like well you
see that and then it inspires you to try
something like that but you don't
necessarily have to be a runner or
endurance athlete you can take that
inspiration and apply it to something
else in your life that that you care
about that may have nothing to do with
that like you know some other goal that
you have that has nothing to do with
anything fitness or athletics related I
get the feeling she wasn't even gonna
apply anything sheesh I think it just
made her it just uplifted her like she
just felt like she was like glowing like
it was just such an uplifting thing to
see these people interesting
there's something about shared suffering
right you know that's it's it's it
brings people together yeah so well
let's talk about suffering tell me about
your relationship to suffering Dean hmm
I'm sure you've never been asked that
it's complicated yeah
you know I embrace it I'll be honest I
mean I think was Pat and who said
and forgive me God for I love it so he
was talking about war but and
ultramarathons of war it's just the
battle is the elements is the mountain
you're facing and you throw yourself
into it and it it I don't know there's
something it tears you down right mmm
but there's there's just something so
raw and visceral about succeeding and
just keeping one foot I mean you saw me
at bad water yeah you want to stop every
step hurts every step you're saying I
got to stop this whole is horrible I
want to stop I want to stop and just
keeping going there's something about
that yeah what is it about that that
makes us feel so alive is it because
that's missing in our day-to-day
equation like we don't have to worry
about survival anymore is it baked into
our DNA or what is the what is the you
know like once you've experienced that
you want more of that you realize like
that thing that we're trying to remove
from our life is the one thing that's
somewhat essential to actually feeling
completely alive and at your best yeah I
you know someone has said that you know
without war you don't know if you're a
coward or hero and this is your war
right every everyone wants to fight and
see what they're made of and this is
this is the test this is where you get
to see you know it nothing holds a
mirror to you like running right
especially long distances you you see
exactly who you are
yeah hmm I think that that it's not it's
not a mystery why you know in addition
to the ultra running community like
exploding you just mentioned some
statistics or how many people run a 5k
like I can't imagine how many people do
marathons like and now we have Spartan
races and we have every derivation of
any kind of crazy endurance obstacle
course challenge imaginable available in
every city on every weekend all across
the developed world why is that
happening now and I think it's because
we've drained our our daily existence
from strain and toil we've created these
air-conditioned castles that we live in
and we're constantly being bombarded
with these messages that the path to
happiness is lined with luxury and ease
and comforts' and you know a flat-screen
TV and the like and that is not
perpetuating happiness and fulfillment
and purpose but rather creating a mass
epidemic of depression and disconnection
and disaffected we have all of these
people who are incredibly unfulfilled in
their professional and personal lives in
a way that that I think is unprecedented
in human history
and it is a ill that is that is that is
endemic to the most modern of societies
and these events are like the antidote
to that in some way they're a way for
people to step outside of this construct
that we've created and tap into
something primal and real that that
makes us human beings god bless you that
was really well stay that was a poet
that was that was in poetry there people
I couldn't said that better that was
that was poetry I mean I could agree
with you more rich and you know you go
to an executives office and you know
what's behind them at their desk you
know their metal from finishing Iron Man
hmm I mean that it becomes more
important than anything else in your
life right it's not the you know what
you've achieved you know what things you
have it's hey I finished Iron Man yeah
if there's something about it that just
goes beyond material it goes beyond its
human it's very human it's a very human
instinct and unfortunately like when you
travel across this country so many
people are so far removed from that I
mean they they don't have a relationship
with their body first of all and that's
horrible
and they've they've kind of just got I
think sucked into this whole world that
you just described of comfort thinking
that's gonna make them happy and you're
bombarded with messaging from marketers
and ads saying just that you know buy
this luxury vehicle and you're gonna be
happy and it doesn't work it just
doesn't that formula doesn't work and I
think more and more people are starting
to recognize that yeah you you when you
finally get the car
the job you're happy for a little bit
and then it just becomes that's your job
or that's the car that you drive yeah
and then you think well it must be the
next car or if I just get that next
promotion you're just on this ladder on
this treadmill of constantly chasing the
next thing without having the
introspection to to look within and
understand that you know that hole is
never going to get filled in that way
and that the path towards what it is
that you're lacking and seek the most is
going to come from getting outside your
comfort zone from embracing adventure
and experience and you know tapping into
that thing that is that is that does
make us human that does require us to
suffer and meet our meet ourselves in a
place of vulnerability that just isn't
you know part of our of how we currently
live well and I think unfortunately a
lot of people listening this we're
probably saying well Dean and rich are
so blessed like they've created these
ideal life's that they just love I'm not
like that like I have to go the office
I've got this I got this obligation you
don't have to go to the office I mean
you can carve out your own niche
everyone can do that I think a lot of
people feel trapped but that's because
they are trapped they've made themselves
trapped there you know that who was it a
said you know that we all live in a cage
with the door wide open we are all in
cages and we all create our own heaven
or hell yeah it's up to us yeah that's a
good point I mean I think it's easy to
look at your life or my life and just
say well you know they have it easier
but like you I mean you quite literally
burst out of your cage and good night to
escape it mine came a little bit later
and was a you know a little less
dramatic and immediate but it was the
same thing it was like I I don't want to
be part of this system anymore I've got
to find a different way to live my life
and took me a very long time to figure
out how to do that well and let me let
me plug in my book let me plug Rich's
book if you haven't read finding ultra
please read that book it is a hell of a
story it's a hell of a story I just wish
I'd burst out of the pen and run all the
way to you know however far you ran rich
the House moon
he wasn't always what he is today
believe me that's the episode are you
trying to walk up your stairs when you
were well he wasn't quite as slender as
he was as he is today not quite in the
day not quite but but I had to put
myself I think that you know speaking
from my own experience the I had been an
athlete in college and I knew I knew
that relationship between suffering and
meaning like I had touched that in my
past and for some reason I felt like I
needed to reconnect with that in order
to answer this question about what I
wanted to do with my life and it wasn't
a direct it's not a direct calculus I
just knew that the answers that eluded
me that I was seeking would be found
with me out alone spending time in
nature with no other sound other than my
breath my heart beating and you know
sweating and and trying to get to that
that that that that place of purity that
only comes when you're completely
stripped down yeah and I mean you know
that's part of the reason I'm involved
with Chicken Soup for the Soul and this
running for good because you get to read
about 101 people that did just as you're
describing I mean every single story is
just what you described and I think it's
empowering for other people to read that
it almost gives them permission like you
know hey my neighbor did this I can
really wait you know or like I can't you
know I can't connect with Dean or I
can't connect with rich but I can
connect with this veteran who has PTSD
or this mom or this person who's who you
know has an amputated limb yeah even I
mean you know even just everyday
hardships you know people that couldn't
walk to the end of their driveway to get
the newspaper they were so obese like
she couldn't walk to the end of a
driveway and she stopped this is
something's gonna happen here and now
she's running half marathons Wow so yeah
what are what are some of your other
favorite excerpts from the book well
there's a there's another crew member at
badwater for me named Michelle Barton I
think you know Michelle and after she
crewed for me she got inspired to
actually run it rich so I think you got
to go back and actually run it and she
tells her story of running bad water and
you think I had it rough
she should read her story yeah why what
happened
she don't spoil it yeah I mean well I'll
just say blisters under the toenails for
one yeah I mean she had it really tough
and she finished Wow and and and what
else there's so many stories in here a
friend of mine burr Pernell took his
family to Greece he went on vacation and
they saw some refugees so if you've ever
been to Greece which I'm Greek so on
some of the islands there's refugee
camps from Syria people trying to get
out of Syria and his daughter asked him
dad what are the why those people behind
the gates and he explained to her that
they're refugees and she is so touched
her she said I don't like this I don't
want people to be like this so he
contacted the aid workers and said you
know what I want we want to get involved
what can I do and they said well you're
a runner why don't you take some of the
young boys running like these these boys
they're young kids like they have no you
know there's there's no outlet for them
so we started a running group on lesbos
for these young Syrian refugee boys yeah
that's amazing yeah it was incredible
the story I'm tearing up just reading
about it yeah that's super cool and how
about it is self selfless is that I mean
think about that daughter we're going to
some resort in Greece you know it's all
great and all of a sudden they're in
these refugee camps instead yeah yeah
but that's an experience they'll never
forget never know it's amazing yeah and
what a what a beautiful thing to do with
your daughter that's I mean for her how
transformational is that to see what
your dad did yeah yeah wow that's
amazing man you got to read the book I
know well I just started there's so many
stories part of it is like I don't need
motivation to run yeah I mean like I
need to be inspired because it's like
that's what I prefer to do like you
actually have to inspire me or motivate
me to do something else other than yeah
but I love you know the heartfelt
stories of just everyday people who find
meaning and purpose through the most
simplest of endeavors which is putting
one foot in front of the other and get
any more like basic or elemental than
that
what do you think he would do if
something happened god forbid and you
couldn't run anymore have you thought
about that ever I've always defined my
finish line as a pine box so I don't
like answering hypothetical questions
you know I one thing I'm doing right now
which I don't think I told you about is
I'm getting a classics degree from
Villanova so I'm gonna graduates
I love ancient Greek culture so I'm
getting a Class six degree and that's
really fulfilling that's cool yeah you
can do that remotely from Marin or do
you have to go to Villanova no it's I
got to go to Villanova and I'm at the
end to defend my thesis but it's all
remote what is your thesis on I haven't
gotten there yet
yeah I'm oh no no I don't know yet but
it's gonna have something to do with
probably with creeks and running running
frogs yeah air Greeks and athletes yes
yeah well when we were when we were
running through the night in bad water
you were telling me all about this
amazing professor that you found who was
the the guy when it came to you know the
running culture of ancient Greece
Hartlage dr. Cartledge from Cambridge
University yep he's the piece profoundly
influenced me this guy is a walking
encyclopedia Wikipedia I mean he knows
more about ancient history
he's amazing he speaks I think six
languages you know fluid Greek he speaks
Latin I mean it's just amazing guy and
he's so humph if he was here he's so
humble and unassuming he's just the
greatest guy yeah so he really
influenced me to you know pursue this
degree Wow so focusing on Greek history
mm-hmm so what have you learned about
Greek history and that culture since you
wrote the book as a result of this
classics program that things go full
circle that the Greeks were wiser than
we are today and a lot of the stuff
we're talking about these very
fundamental ways of achieving happiness
you know if you read Plato you'll read
Socrates that's what they talk about so
it's it's not a lot different than this
conversation mmm yeah
because they were facing the same thing
the Greeks there was a huge income
disparity in ancient Greece people were
living frivolous lifes of excess yeah
and they were saying no don't it's not
gonna that's that
the wrong direction again yeah and this
is 2500 years ago have you studied the
Stoics at all I have is now this is such
a psyche ice tea thing everybody's all
about the Stoics because ryan holiday in
his amazing books not least of which is
right here he goes the enemy yeah and
it's it's fascinating that this you know
this cannon of ancient wisdom is now
been made so popular and i think in part
it's because it's so practical and
relevant to the problems that we're
having today like we're having like
these these ruminations whether it's
Marcus Aurelius or Seneca or epictetus
they're prayin that you got a Greek and
Roman when they re coming in there yeah
I mean they write about the problems
that they're facing and if you can kind
of extract out you know whatever is
relevant to that time and age you
realize like these are the same things
that occupy our unconscious and
conscious minds on a day to day basis
how to be more productive how to
prioritize what's most important you
know how to focus our lives around
meaning and purpose and fulfillment and
and and the like and I think because of
the way the things that we've already
talked about here today there is a
crisis of of people trying to find a
meaning in their lives because they're
pursuing careers that are not as
fulfilling as perhaps they would have
been 20 or 30 or 40 or 50 or 200 years
ago and it's leading that imaginary
we're talking 25 right here Tony
bringing people back to this these
ancient texts where these people spent a
lot of time thinking about this stuff
and trying to construct pathways forward
that are practical you know it to me
that's what it was it was so profound to
read these you know the messaging from
ancient Greece and say these are the
same issues we're facing today and you
know what are the strategies to overcome
and they're not a lot different than
what we're talking about right now right
yeah right you should just be naked
below the Acropolis you know eating
grapes drinking wine hi other than that
it's all good and and the occasional 55
mile training right yeah so when you go
back to Greece for this race are you
gonna do it in the true
Garr began hell that was a one-and-done
yeah yeah so the first time if for those
of you listening Iran eating only the
ancient Greek food so I ran with cured
meat like a beef jerky something that
called pastila which is a ground sesame
seed and honey oh it's almost like a
energy paste nuts you know just basic
foods that fit dippity ancient
marathoner would have used and it was
not a good experience okay and you had
like the skirt and the sandals too
didn't you for at least four part of it
right Iran that I did a marathon oh it's
good right those are you having things
yeah I was gonna try and test wearing it
like how would it go and it didn't go so
well and the foods went well the foods I
ran I did like 10 12 hour training runs
but what I learned is you can eat figs
for 10 or 12 hours that's fine
yeah when you eat figs for 20 for 30
hours you can't live on figs for obvious
reasons yeah why do you eat FIGS yeah
this is the fallacy of like we should
get back to the way we used to do things
taking in too far it's like just because
they did that that long ago doesn't mean
that that was the best way to we're
trying to we've learned a few things
since and they weren't running 153 miles
you know non-stop for 36 hours they were
eating figs throughout the day which is
fine or even in a short run but 36 hours
of figs is not good on the stomach yeah
no talk about having to pull over to the
side right huh why do you think that
you've been able to from what I can tell
like I don't think you've ever sustained
an overuse injury is that true yeah I
mean I shouldn't say that because I'm
probably trip on the doors right his
doorstep and break my leg when I walk
out of here but yeah I'd never had an
injury
never never achilles nothing nothing
rich Wow
I do a lot of cross-training uh-huh tell
me walk me through like that routine and
and maybe how its evolved over the years
so I do I have this routine of hit
training so I have an office just like
yours oh you've seen my house and I've
got a pull-up bar and a sit-up mat and
throughout the course of the day and I'm
never sitting like we're doing now I'm
standing you know answering emails
whatever right I'm standing
standing desk and then I do I did this I
hit cycle it's about 12 to 13 minutes
push-ups sit-ups pull-ups chair dips and
burpees mm-hmm and it keeps my heart
revved for the whole time you're pretty
much red lining the whole time and I do
maybe five or six of those throughout
the course of the day all with body
weight right no actual weights yeah so
you're at your desk do you type if you
work for 15-20 minutes and then you do
like a little routine and then return
back to the desk so you're and they have
just repeat or constantly kind of so
you're just kind of constantly in a
perpetual state of training contract
exactly exactly and when you're what is
what is what is writing a book look like
for you that because for me like I have
to sit and I have to like I can't do it
in tiny chunks like I have to really sit
for hours and hours and hours and like
Mayer mice like marinate and I can't get
their thoughts okay
dictate on a headset or something like
Anna I've tried meditation I can I've
got to be moving like I cannot meditate
to me you know motions stirs emotion so
I run and write I mean I literally run I
dictate into my iPhone now but I run I
write a lot of verses while I'm running
well and that's when you can you can
really work craft a sentence when you're
running cuz you think about permutations
or you know how are you gonna say how
you're gonna say what you're gonna say
how best to say it how creatively to say
it and when you're running you just have
your clearest thoughts I do at least huh
yeah so you just pull it out and do like
a voice memo yep right yeah and you know
I can memorize entire pitch sometimes
two or three paragraphs and that I'm
thinking wow big [ __ ] right but I mean
the old leaders that read The Odyssey
they were you know they're right reading
they were memorizing 9,000 sentence
basically 9,000 sentences nine thousand
lines of towns they memorized and they
orally you know give their orations over
the course of five or six hours every
single word perfect those guys need a
they need to get a life there was no
there was no Twitter feed there is no
distractions there's nothing else for
them to do right
an Instagram of a moment I'm at 8999 I'm
gonna nail this last sentence get this
mom wow that's amazing yeah so then you
take that so I'm just trying to like
kind of crock the process so you would
do that and then you come back and then
transcribe it or how does that work yeah
go transcribe it exactly yeah has a
glass of water
sit down transcribe and also you know
when you come to an end of a chapter
you're thinking what direction do I take
this book right I mean you know what's
the story gonna be so thinking about how
you're gonna you know craft the next
paragraph or the next even the next
chapter even the next you know half a
book like which direction is gonna go
you're gonna talk about this now let's
talk about this you know it's like
writing right it's a lot of thinking
yeah that is the definition of effective
multitasking if you're training and
writing your book at the same time you
may be I think it's I think is the best
time to do it I really I mean anyone
listen this I'm no they're saying that
yeah I have my best sauce when I'm
running as well it's an F through yeah I
think they need to figure out a more
seamless way of like trying to you know
if you're running then pulling out your
phone and then like how are you like
tight you know like if there was a
really easy way to just go fit and you
know push one button or whatever and let
it let it flow I don't know yeah that'd
be easy I've got I've got a handle on my
phone so I just run with my phone and
just yeah voice dictation voice memo yes
interesting I'm gonna try I'm gonna try
that
but you don't listen to any music or I
listen to audiobooks what you do yeah
yeah no podcasts of course though you
don't every single one
come on he's lying that is amazing about
never never having had an overuse injury
like no back problem so nothing like
that like that is true that's remarkable
I think you're you're unique in that and
I that must be it has to be because of
all the cross-training that you're doing
because the running without that there's
no way I think it's a 360 degree view
that allows me to be the best animal I
can be so I look at my entire life
through the lens of being the best
runner I can be so that means we know
training cross-training that means good
quality sleep
it means diet it's everything but I also
think it means interpersonal
relationships like if you have good
stable interpersonal relationships your
performance is a lot better if if your
interpersonal relationships are
disruptive and you have you know you're
battling with people it impacts a
performance mm-hmm we know this and so
that's the other thing I try to optimize
is my interpersonal relationships you
know part of things you talk about is
you know you associate with people that
that bring you up right you don't
associate with people that bring you
down and you know that that's been a
lesson I've learned yeah and also you
associate maybe with fewer people I mean
I'm an introvert so I have fewer closer
friends and I'm very comfortable on my
own like a lot of people I think are not
comfortable by themselves like I don't
mind running with myself for three hours
I'm not bored yeah I get I'm cold being
by myself yeah I prefer it but you must
have people rolling up on you on the
trails all the time oh I have some funny
things happen yeah or even on the roads
I totally you know I mean even in the
airport walking here when I was going
through TSA on in Oakland the TSA guys
like oh my god you're the you're that
ultra marathoner bride you're the runner
guy like my god you're amazing you know
he's very discreet and I said I thanks
bro yeah those sort of things happen all
the time
yeah well that's nice yeah I know you're
being acknowledged for for who you are
that's cool yeah but it's different if
it's like if you're trying to get into
that if you're like literally writing
while you're running and your handle and
then someone wants to run with you or
you know like like show you up or
something like that oh that's the
ultramarathon guy like I'm gonna race
him yeah I know I passed a guy couple
days ago and he saw me and he he was
standing on the trail side just catching
his breath and it was really a hot day
and he saw me run by so he obviously
caught up to me chatted it was a it was
a fine conversation you know and he
lasted a couple miles but people are
respectful yeah you know it's good
people rich like I don't have I'm like a
movie star rock star where I have all
these you know fawning fans the people
that come up to me and say hey man like
really nice to meet you there like I
would sit down have a beer with this guy
like they're really solid people so I
feel pretty lucky in that regard
yeah yeah and how often are you going
out and doing like the you know just you
show up at these 5ks 10ks marathons like
you just need to do that a lot I do it's
it's you know it's sponsorship sort of
stuff right do I do it quite a bit yeah
how many sponsors are you working with
now it's fluid yeah you know that's the
other thing with my life and I'm sure
like yours you're just I mean I'm an
ideal chaser you're constantly chasing
your next deal like you're never sure
how much how long the sponsorships gonna
last you never show you who the next
one's gonna be so you're always
prospecting and you're always chasing
sponsors so that's you know that's a
pretty tough element and you do that all
you do that yourself yeah yeah I tried
working with a couple agencies and they
just they don't get in during sports
like you get lost with the basketball
players and the football players and
you're just you know let's face it
you're you know you're small potatoes
compared to those guys in certain
respects yes and in other ways no like I
feel like that's shifting but not
shifting quite a bit my sense is that
most you know most of the large
companies or the companies that would be
candidates for sponsoring a person like
yourself have a certain way in which
they perceive athletes it's like these
are the you know these are the people
that we work with this is their race
schedule these are the podiums they're
gonna be on this is the kit that they're
gonna wear and here's where our logo is
going to be and it's a very kind of
binary way of thinking where is I look
at someone like yourself and your appeal
like your your your value to a sponsor
has nothing to do with like a podium or
you know whatever gear you're gonna wear
it's it's it's a lifestyle thing and you
have the ability to reach so many people
and so many different kinds of people
and you bring in all of these people who
have no idea who's first second or third
at this race or that race this is not
part of their universe and yet what you
speak to is meaningful for these people
and so it's confusing to me why more
sponsors don't understand the value of
that because I actually think that's
more valuable than some guy who can run
you know a 212 marathon but is somebody
that
ever heard of rich that pitch you just
gave me
how many executives I've laid that same
pitch and they look at me blunt like
like with the glazed over like well you
know your name's not on the side of
staple stadium I mean you know they
don't they don't get up yeah I get it
you know it's hard man you got to be a
hustler it's like back to like hey this
is the life that you wanted and this is
the life that you're creating for
yourself you're forging you know a
situation that is without precedent so
yeah who would have thought like a guy
who is super into running ultra
marathons and is really good at it could
create not just a vocation out of it but
one with longevity you know like that
that's not an easy thing and yet you've
been able to do it year after year after
year well I mean I look to models people
like you like save well I follow in your
footsteps we look at like Laird Hamilton
like you know he's a big wave surfer I
don't know how much does he surf these
days probably not as much as I mean surf
every day cuz he lives out here you know
ya see him around and stuff like that
but he's not competing he's not a
competitive surfer yeah or Tony Hawk I
mean how did he carve out a make a go of
it skateboarding you who would ever
think you could do this but they figured
you can make a cool video game on escape
you're just gonna run on this trail for
the next 55 hours let's see if you how
many Red Bulls you're gonna drink that
lazy boy chair before you Falls
oh he's gonna pee again let's get that
one extra bonus points for not having
diarrhea oh I don't know come on graphic
you know it's true though yeah like Pete
I you know Laird is probably the best
example or Tony Hawk like people who
excelled at what they do but if still
you know I've been able to create a life
out of it that that extends beyond the
paradigm of competition yeah you know
yeah so what's next for you man you got
these races coming up but that's the
longer view you just keep writing books
keep writing another book like that's
not there you're only as good as your
next book right that's a saying so I'm
writing another book I just I sold
motion picture rights to ultramarathon
yeah yeah so it's who's shopping around
it's a producer on the East Coast uh-huh
Sergio Ria's and he's a really good guy
that's excited young kid he read my book
he like lost you know I think he lost 80
pounds he was living in Idaho and he's
like changed his life and he's yeah so
that's exciting
what else I just won I was given the
President's Council on sports fitness
and nutrition I just won the Lifetime
Achievement Award Wow
so I get to go back to Washington DC and
get a school when they give you a fancy
metal I apply I hope to you I I let's
not go there okay because our current
guy at the top is not necessarily the
the the pitcher of fitness and health is
right he doesn't really embrace this
either now he's gonna hand it to you I
don't know mmm I don't know it's gonna
be interesting to see a should be
interested well congratulations
cool I you know why it's cool to me is
one of my mentors Jack LaLanne was the
first recipient you know really yeah he
was a very first guy and arnold's won it
as well so yeah did they give that out
every year every year yeah Wow yeah
that's cool and how long before you
finish your classics degree yeah yeah -
I've got about two and a half more years
I'm gonna long yeah I'm only taking a
course or two a semester right yeah and
how old are your kids now like run out
of the house get their kid there yeah
I'm an empty nester yeah you know what I
do all day I get up I walk around naked
you know I have some coffee making out
bend over look through the produce
second you know the produce drawer in
the refrigerator and my wife walks
around the corner and I'm bending over
and she's like you can put clothes on
today like you saw where I live like why
yeah why well you're way up at the top
nobody can see in where you care anymore
if they do it feels so good to be naked
uh-huh and you know Socrates used to
take air baths so he'd go stand out
naked in the wind so yeah so did Ben
even Franklin something to be said about
an air bath you gotta try rich it's
really liberating in air bath
that reminds me of that scene in Jerry
Maguire when Cuba Gooding jr. is like
comes out of the shower and Tom Cruise
is like you want to tell and he's like
no air dry though he was tapping into
his inner Socrates I suppose yeah well
that's cool is your is your wife still
practice
dentistry she is tired from that no
she's actually in real estate now oh wow
so she's doing real estate she also
sells transact dental practices so to
sell a dental practice in California you
have to be a licensed dentist and a
licensed realtor so how many of those
exist so she has a little niche on that
one yeah and what are your kids think
about what you do like are they and I
know you've you've done some events with
your son right you ran recipes yeah
they've they've done some run Omaha
they just they don't think anything
right unusual with me yeah my my kids
got bellossom would not be less
interested like my daughters want they
have no interest whatsoever in
participating in any of these things
that like I mean they're like that's
cool dad like but they're not it's not
like when I see other other parents or
dads out there and they get their kids
to do these things well yeah like I
would have to move heaven and earth to
get one of my daughters try to do
something like that like it just David
it's fine like I don't need them to do
that like I yeah it's not like I'm I'm
there to support what it is that lights
them up you know that's what excites me
so it's not like I need that to happen I
just find it curious that the universe
rigs it for me to have kids that like
are interested in things completely
different then what gets me out of bed
yeah well my daughter runs and we've run
you probably like I like this story but
we ran the wine country half marathon so
I'm gonna get angry Napa to Sonoma Wine
Country half and get this at about mile
a to the half marathon they started
serving wine at the age stations so I'm
like Alexander should we she's like
let's wait tomorrow 10:00 so we have
tomorrow 10:00 and I'm like okay let's
indulge those are the best three miles
of my life oh there's another aid
station now I don't mind if you want to
break two hours I don't live there who
cares yeah and you had do you have a
wine company I thought I started a label
yep yeah I'm wines did that inspire you
if we're gonna have wine it should be my
wine I'm on the race course that's what
I thought yeah well I mean how did that
come together it was a collaboration
with the Greek guy I've done a couple
collaborations with people
Greek products so I have a product
called the naked Greek which is a body
lotion these are you know kind of like
licensing deals right I'm starting a CBD
line called on the run mm-hmm
specifically for runners so that's
another one I'm looking forward to a
cool you got to pay the bills somehow
right yeah man yeah you're getting it
so CBD oil wine you had like you did a
body butter your keeper thing for a
while too right yep Greek yogurt as I
said you're constantly chasing the deals
yep it's just the next all that stuff
man faceted Dean Karnazes Mountain tea
and hint
oh that's right yeah thank you for that
so that's your product as well no that's
a friend of mine too two friends of mine
laughs knee and Chloe have a company in
Greece where they go and pick herbs that
way to eat which you try yeah so talk to
me about what Mountain tea is it grows
it's they call it Sheppard tea in some
places it's is it's a it's like a an
herb a flowering herb that grows at high
elevations in Greece like Mount Olympus
and it's energetic it's it's almost like
it's like mate' but it's a little
different yeah and so I mean basically
you just get it's like a you it's rat
it's like the full plant it's not like
tea leaves ya know just get big pot get
a big pot you just warm it boil water in
there throw it in there for like 15
minutes and then strain it out I put a
little Stevie in there for sweetness
it's fantastic is it caffeinated no no
caffeine yeah just some other kind of
well just something like 1200 bioactive
compounds within that tea there's all
kinds of stuff in there beside you know
steel bromine theophylline there's a lot
of other stuff besides caffeine that it
makes you feel good right I look forward
to checking it out thank you know that
well let's let's round this out with a
little bit of takeaway wisdom for people
that are listening I want to kind of
hear it too you know that person who is
you know on the couch but maybe on the
edge of the couch like they're the
person who maybe turns out to witness
the New York Marathon and gets energy
energy from that but hasn't quite made
that extra step to get out there
themselves so how do you communicate or
speak to that individual to try to
fire them to put on a pair of running
shoes and get after it you know I always
tell people to look inward before you
start this journey because let's face it
it's really intimidating to a lot of
people I hear that all the time like
this is so intimidating for me to try to
go running especially if I say let's go
running because there's things I have to
keep up with Dean so if you're an
introvert don't sign up for a group
running program you're gonna hate it
you're gonna feel weird
yes that's what everyone says a group
you'll love it if you're an extrovert
and you want group support and you like
the accountability like every you know
every at 6:00 p.m. on Tuesdays and
Thursdays we're doing our group run
that's a great way to go about it
I also say invest in a good pair of
running shoes like go to a specialty
running store not like a big box not
like a big five or you know Dick's
Sporting Goods go to like a fleet feed
you know one of the grassroots
especially running and get a good pair
of shoes get fitted there's so many
great shoes out there now so get fitted
for a good pair of shoes that'll make
you more comfortable and then again you
know look inside and if you if you like
you know the accountability of being
places and you like group dynamics sign
up I also say pick up pick an event six
months down the road and and sign up
even if it's a 5k register and then
you're accountable and tell people that
you're gonna do it so that you know in
those days when you're feeling I'm not
gonna train today you know you've like
told these people you're gonna do this
thing and and do it for charity it makes
it you even more accountable and raising
money for others now you got to do it
and that helps fuel you along I think a
statistic that really surprised me from
running USA is that something like
eighty percent of the runners start
running to lose weight and like
something like 80 percent of the current
runners run because they enjoy it so
it's it says to me that a lot of people
start running because they want to lose
weight uh-huh and all of a sudden they
find that they like running and so now
they lose their weight or they don't but
they keep running they enjoy the act of
running so just getting someone running
I think is the hardest part yeah I think
that that person who gets into it to
lose weight can't imagine that one day
they would actually enjoy it it's just
like this thing like I have to do it in
order
take off these extra pounds but I'm not
doing it because it's fun it's terrible
I absolutely hate it and it is hard to
get in shape running but once you're in
shape running that's where the fun
begins and it's it's a long process to
like people it just that's the problem
if you could go on one run and the next
day it'd be easier we'd have a lot more
runners but you know it takes a month
before you can actually run a continuous
mile some people I mean some people
cannot run litter I say try to run for
one minute
just set your clock for one minute and
run continuous and they can't make it
when they first start out and then they
make it I say try three minutes mm-hmm
and then make it three minutes so it's
you know that it's very quantifiable
like you know you're making progress if
you just set a time goal and and do it
that way and then you see I'm moving
forward I ran ten minutes non-stop today
even if it starts with just walking
around the block you know I think people
think that they don't want to get into
it because they don't want to look bad
or they feel like they need to be good
at it from the outset and you know we
are all natural-born runners but you
know we've been living sedentary lives
and I think it's okay to give people
permission even before they go to the
Fleet Feet and get measured for you know
the nice pair of shoes to just put on
the Chuck Taylors and the flip-flops and
like walk around yeah walk around the
block and whatever it is that you have
you really don't need not only do you
not need permission you don't really
need anything other than your body to do
it and will power the with the power
yeah yeah have you seen this really
great new independent movie Britney runs
a marathon I saw the head that yeah I
haven't seen it yet though have you seen
it I um it's great the I mean it's not
so much about running right I mean it
isn't it isn't it's better than the
trailer it's a really great movie and it
is about this woman Britney and how her
life has kind of gone sideways and she
gets into running initially yes to lose
weight but then you know becomes like
she's like I'm a runner now and it and
it starts to inform how she makes
decisions about her life so it's really
about her regaining control over her
life and setting her on a path
to respect herself and the marathon is
just a part of that but it in it's it's
like this is how she evolves it's
fantastic I can't wait this my buddy
Karsh plays her love interest in the
movie and he's been on the podcast so
that makes it extra special so you see
her love interest yeah well he's like
clinically it's like that on-again
off-again you have love interest in the
movie and it's it's really it's really
well done is he a runner in the movie
there no it's not all right he's not
it's super fun movie so yeah you would
love it actually I think it's great and
I think it would inspire anybody to -
who thinks like well I'm not a runner
and I can't do that like the whole kind
of narrative is about this person who
thinks that way as well and proves to
herself otherwise I I applaud the
producer director everyone in that
because if I bet they're gonna inspire a
lot of people to start running yeah it's
based on a true story the writer
director had a roommate when he was
living in New York and it was based on
this woman's story and how inspired he
was about how she went on this journey
for herself and it took in many years
but you know he's made this movie and
it's really cool yeah so all right well
Bravo
final party and closing words inspire me
Dean Karnazes remin you can walk if you
have to crawl if you must just never
give up that's your mantra have to go -
yeah I got some others but that one's
always a good one well I just I want to
publicly acknowledge you for the amazing
example that you set for millions of
people I think the work that you do is
is truly meaningful it inspired me I
don't know that I would be sitting here
without the path that you blazed ahead
of me and the example that you've set
for me and the mentorship that you've
shown me so I really appreciate your
friendship and and your counsel and it
means a lot to me that you would come
here today and share your message with
everybody so thank you I'm much more
comfortable running with you than
sitting here yeah yeah one of these days
we're gonna get the heck out of too much
podcast for you at bad water
I have too much respect for that that
would that would that would need need a
major life rearrangement maybe when I'm
an empty nester okay you're on you're on
the record don't cut this out what out
all right thanks come back and any time
come back and share share with me when
you finish your classics degree when you
got the next book thanks for having me
rich I appreciate it peace Dean
[Music]